For those of you joining us now,...
...we have breaking news from the front lines...
...where a few men are stranded between the two armies.
No one knows who they are.
No one knows which side they're on.
And no one wants to get involved.
Sir, neither side will help the men in the trench.
We do not know if they would actually decide to do something.
But what do you expect me to do?
I mean, you can't expect me to risk the lives of our soldiers...
...in order to save theirs, can you?
But Sir?
Tell him it is usual neither side can agree.
Two enemies are becoming the victims...
...in a war between the newsmakers and the peacekeepers.
What started as a minor problem...
Hello.
He needs help.
...is about to become a major incident.
No.
We move him, mine boom.
United Artists proudly presents...
...the highly-acclaimed winner of the Special Jury Prize...
...Cannes Film Festival 2001...
I can do nothing.
Get back into the trench. Pretend to be dizzy.
Okay we go, you...
...don't shoot. Nobody shoots.
Yeah.
"A modern catch-22," exclaims Roger Ebert.
This whole business stinks to high heaven.
"Eloquently simple, virtually unforgettable," raves Newsday.
Did you get it?
No Man's Land